how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and the multiverse
coming up
it looks like one vision is going to
kick off the multiverse possibly having
it explode or burst
into madness leading into doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness and as the
president of marvel studios kevin feige
has confirmed it will
also directly lead into spider-man 3
with tom holland and hopefully toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man as well
a lot has been happening with spider-man
3 so many rumors and reports from
different media outlets have come out
but today we have an official update
from tom holland himself
talking about spider-man 3 with variety
he also talked a little bit yesterday
about spider-man 3 as well which we'll
cover
so if you love spider-man and you love
marvel be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news
so let's start off with the variety
interview with tom
holland and of course variety was there
to talk to him about his upcoming film
cherry but right now you can't really
interview tom holland
without talking about spider-man 3 and
the madness that it is supposed to be
all the different rumors that toby
maguire spider-man is showing up andrew
garfield spider-man is coming up alfred
molina's doc ock is confirmed to be in
the movie along with jamie foxx's
electro is confirmed as well
and also plenty of other characters
rumored to come in as well
tom holland dropped a pretty bold
statement in his variety interview about
spider-man 3.
variety says and i quote with upcoming
roles and not just
cherry the british star is also
currently filming the still
untitled spider-man sequel from director
john watts
holland opens up about preparing for his
role as a soldier turned
drug addict and then turned bank robber
along with what we can expect from the
new superhero movie next year which he
calls
the most ambitious standalone superhero
movie
ever made now i'll dive into what he
means by standalone movie in just a
second but he had more to say about
spider-man 3.
variety went on to ask can you tell us
anything about the upcoming spider-man
movie that you're filming and tom
holland said obviously i can't really
say anything but then variety jokingly
asked
you can tell us what happens at the end
right in which tom holland said
what's funny is like i nearly told you
then you were so close to getting what
you want
i can say that it's the most ambitious
standalone superhero movie ever made
you sit down read the script and see
what they're trying to do
and they're succeeding it's really
impressive i've never seen a standalone
superhero movie quite like it
and i'm just you know again that lucky
little guy who happens to be spider-man
in it
we got a lot more shooting to do we
started before christmas and shot it for
like
seven weeks we stopped for the christmas
break and then we're starting again
i'm just as excited as anyone else to
see it let alone be a part of it
so tom holland is really excited about
it and just a few days ago he posted to
instagram saying
that he shot something that was easily
one of the highlights of his career for
those of you that were there you know
what i'm talking about and for those of
you that weren't you better buckle up
and in the picture he posted it was of
him and his brother now we obviously
know that his brother's going to play
some role in the film so we don't think
that's what he's talking
about of course what we think he's
talking about is filming with toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man
and when tom holland has repeatedly said
standalone film
in this interview we think it's because
he's trying to throw us off
we've gotten a ton of reports from major
outlets
very reputable outlets stating that this
is indeed going to be a spider-verse
film but we have got
absolutely nothing from sony or marvel
even though sony did promise us a first
look at spider-man 3 by the end of the
year which we did not get
they are really trying to avoid having
everybody know that this is going to be
a multiverse film
so this is most likely just tom holland
trying to throw us off
but in an interview yesterday he did say
that it is absolutely
insane and another hint that it isn't in
fact a standalone movie is that he
said that spider-man 3 is really
impressive he's never seen a standalone
superhero movie quite like it and he's
just
the little guy who happens to be
spider-man in it that implies that there
are other
people in it and tom holland is a part
of this group that is going to be in the
movie
now i do think it is still primarily
going to focus on tom holland spider-man
but of course i also think it's going to
be a spider-verse film
but hopefully we get something official
from sony or marvel sometime soon or get
a leaked photo that perhaps reveals
something
since he said they're filming again
hopefully something comes out soon
but let me know what you think about
what tom holland said in this interview
with variety in the comments down below
and again don't forget to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
spider-man and mcu news
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof